[Music]
we've been married for almost 30 years
and I do not feel sexual desire for my
husband and with few exceptions I really
never have how do I fix the sexual side
of my marriage he deserved to have had
that conversation 30 freaking years ago
[Music]
Jane woo what's up this is John with the
Dr on deloney
show it's a show about your marriage
your kids your emotional mental health I
whatever you got going on in your life
you sit with real people going through
real challenges if you want to be on
this show talk about things that are
going on things that you're struggling
with what to do next you're struggling
with the diagnostic you just got a
diagnosis you're struggling with how to
deal with your kids in the schools your
marriage is falling apart whatever's
going on give me a buzz at 1844 693 3291
it's 1844 4693
3291 or go to john.com
askk and we are recording the show in
the old year but we are in the New Year
assuming we survived I always have this
little thing that we might not make the
new year but so far we've done it every
every one of the new years I've been a
part of we've we've all collectively
made it you are such a catastrophist and
I don't know if that's a real word or
not but you know what you're the
producer you can say whatever you want
to it's a word I made up for you I'm a
catastrophist you are a catastrophist
that's the name of our new and the
catastrophists I love it I'm I'm in on
that and I think that's the tattoo we
should all get for Christmas I'm buying
them that's the that's the that's the
team gift this year is we're all getting
tattoos gonna have to return that
gift you can't return a tattoo that's
not how they work which is why you were
not in honors classes all right let's go
out to St Paul Minnesota and talk to
Jane Sweet Jane what's
up um hi Dr Loney thanks for taking my
call of course how we doing I'm uh not
not too bad how about yourself not too
bad not too bad either not too bad
either what's up good good um I'm just
gonna read my question because I'm
really nervous if that's okay of course
of course it is okay so my question is
actually twofold number one should I be
completely honest with my husband during
difficult conversations about our sex
life and number two how do I fix the
sexual side of my
marriage um um I have some cont is there
some cont there you go no let's just
answer it like that um yeah go ahead
okay okay so um we've been married for
almost 30 years and I do not feel sexual
desire for my husband um and with few
exceptions I really never have we're
best friends platonically but I've never
felt spontaneous or responsive sexual
desire um and I've tried prayer
counseling porn hormone level testing
religion ignoring the problem completely
meditation anti-depressants alcohol lots
and lots of Faking it and nothing has
worked so I'm worried about being 85
someday and feeling regret that I didn't
experience sexual connection and desire
um my husband has called me out several
times over the years for not being
sexually attracted to him and I lie and
deny it because I love him and I don't
want to hurt him but he obviously feels
it yeah um sometimes I I'll I'll answer
answer this in reverse order sometimes
we don't want to hurt people that we
love especially about a sensitive topic
like this and that so much of our
personal identity is wound up in it
right and
um we hedge the truth or we don't tell
them the full truth because we don't
want to hurt them and that makes them
feel crazy because they feel that they
feel you're not in right they feel they
feel the Gap if you will
relationally and um instead of giving
them a hard answer that we can fix or we
can solve or at least deal with once
it's on the table um we tell them no no
no no I'm I'm totally into you sexually
or I'm totally into moving or I'm
totally into how we're raising our kids
and they know something's not right so
they end up trying to fix it and solve
it and then they go crazy um so yes to
reverse answer I don't see a path
forward that doesn't start with telling
the truth the question I would ask you
is what about your relationship has
prohibited you for 30 years to not be
able to tell the
truth I I think really just that I I
don't want to hurt his feelings but like
in my house in my house my wife and I
know
that hurting feelings going through that
pain is the only path forward to
resolving whatever is on the table which
means not that we're not going to hurt
each other's feelings but we have to
create a context where it's okay to say
what's true and for whatever reason
either you have taken on a maternal role
with your husband
it's your job is to make sure he feels
okay it's which is different than I want
to connect with him um the second or the
second is he's created a world where
it's not safe for you to tell the truth
in that
house I it's probably more the the first
I just don't I don't know maybe I'm
afraid of consequences of the
conversation like I I don't know I think
over time he said things like well you
either feel it or you don't um and and
so it's almost like if I follow that up
by admitting it out loud then it's like
kind of game over in his mind like I
should have it or I don't have it and if
I don't have it there's no fixing it
that's that's the impression I've always
gotten and so well that's I mean that's
that's that's somebody reaching out out
of pain because he's probably watched
you try a whole bunch of stuff
and in his mind he's not
enough right and so it's easy to come up
with some simplistic that sounds very
like a politician well it's good of this
well no it's not there's a lot of nuance
there there's a lot of stuff there and
so um it sounds like you you're asking
for two
things you want to preserve this
marriage as it is with your quote
unquote best friend in the world and you
also don't want to be 90 and wonder what
it would have been like to have a
reckless wild sexually romantic
marriage right it's almost like if you
tell the truth you know this thing's
over or at least the illusion that the
fake thing you'all had is over
over right that's true so I don't know
if I need to I don't want to preserve
the fake thing anymore though yeah not
that's why I'm calling well it like I'm
never GNA tell somebody to continue to
lie about something that's not
right okay I'll never tell them that
which means you got to deal with a hard
gnarly truth on the back end and that's
scary too it's been going on for three
decades let me ask you a hard question
what else have you not told him the
truth about you don't hurt his feelings
because there's more than just
this
um I mean I guess there's just you know
normal marriage stuff I mean stuff that
annoys me so stuff that annoys me and I
I just don't say anything because I
think he thinks it's part of his
personality and I I again don't I don't
want to hurt him I don't want to like
squash who he is um so you you've you've
been to diagnose any go ahead well you
you know you finish what you were gonna
say I I don't want to diagnose anyone
because that's your job or somebody
else's job but he has a lot of things
that I would consider ADHD is like um
you know Timeless overt talking
interrupting oversharing kind of a
verbal diarrhea you know type thing um
and it's you know it's like an
embarrassing feeling sometimes when
we're with other people and so I
I avoid being with other people with him
over the years not that you know we
Hermits or anything but um I don't
know some of those things I've just
never I mean I maybe brought them up
very mildly but I just always kind of
back off of them I don't tell them how
much it's bothering me you know and what
effect it's had on
me I hate that for you and I hate that
for
him I really do but I feel like if I
tell him he's going to be like well then
you basically don't like anything about
me you know yeah but he deserved to have
had that conversation 30 freaking years
ago
Jane because he could have done
something different with his life and
you could have done something different
with yours
or one of the this is anic data behind
closed doors is when I meet with people
with ADHD especially
couples what I often hear is my God this
person's banana and it's tough to live
with and my god when they are plugged in
they're the greatest lover on planet
Earth but you haven't given y y'all I
mean geez I often don't say this but
you've you've perpetu wh why have you
stayed in this what do what did you get
out of
it I mean we get along no you don't you
do not Jane you don't you know why you
don't like him you don't like him he's a
kid to you he's your child he's an adult
son you don't like how he is in public
you don't think his jokes are funny you
think they're inappropriate he doesn't
he's late to stuff you're not attracted
to him you don't want to sleep with him
he's not your friend he's he's like a
pet
right I'm just using your words give me
something
back no I
I I can't refuse a lot of that but I do
find him funny we're in sync he's a good
dad I mean like there's just a lot of
things that I do appreciate about him
where but you don't you don't like
him I don't like some of his behaviors I
didn't say I didn't like him but you
don't like him enough to tell him the
truth for three decades and and here's
here's what I'm saying um I'm not saying
he's perfect in any way and he's got a
lot of stuff to
change I I'm speaking as a guy who
struggles with some of the things he
struggles with and I'm so blessed that I
had a wife sit down with me while she
was still my girlfriend and then early
on and then as we figured it out
later to just be honest with me about
how she was experiencing
me and that I can't imagine waking up 30
years and knowing that most of the
romance in my life has been
fraudulent because I know what it's like
to go to bed at night thinking the whole
thing is your fault
and it's just I mean god dude it's it's
it's so yes you have to tell the truth
period okay okay the second thing is is
I don't know a lot of intimacy I don't
know anyone that can experience deep
intim intimacy especially over
time with a
lie that's that's the big the secrets
are the
Gap and for you said you've never felt
sexually attracted to
him well I mean I did when we were
dating you know obviously not obviously
because I would have said obviously
you've told him the truth for 30 years
and you haven't done that are you do you
find yourself sexually attracted to
other
people um no I mean it no
okay I mean if I see like a really
good-look guy am am I going to turn my
head well yeah I mean I'm human but not
like I'm pursuing other people or
anything no no I I I'm I'm is he is your
husband for 30 years so he's the be in
the brunt of the weight of your your
lack of like the gap between how sexual
you want to be and what's actually
happening in real life but my question
is are you would you classify yourself
as as someone who is asexual just I'm
not into it or they just I I have gone
through this and this and this and this
and I'm not into it or I'm just into a
that
guy and there's a difference there
probably the second I think probably the
ladder I so let's let's play this out
let's play this out you and him break up
tomorrow you just call
it and you immediately get
tnder and you swipe right and some other
dude swipes right and yall meet up do
you think it would that would be the
that would be the Alchemy you've been
looking for
that there's somebody else out there
that you would feel rambunctiously
sexually attracted
to I don't know probably
not I guess I don't know I I have no
idea I've not thought about that
honestly you have to have thought about
it some because you spent a lot of time
thinking about hit not be I mean it not
being him right or maybe maybe you hav't
at all I I just want it to be in our
marriage like I feel connected to him
on I'm connected to him we've been
together for almost 30 years right and
I I want to do the right thing here
finally maybe or not maybe I do want to
do the right thing for for his sake and
for mine you know yeah um so let's be
real specific about your needs what what
are they if you had to if you had to
write down on paper here's my sexual
needs what are
they I want to be connected to him and
feel like he's connected to me you've
for 30 years you've not allowed him to
be connected to you so let's go deeper
than that like that's a that's an
amorphous answer right so that starts
with telling the truth but let's get
beneath that be very specific what are
you what are you missing you don't like
how he smells you don't like him without
a shirt on like what all that is
fine um I mean he's attractive don't get
me wrong it's not like you know either
one of us is I don't know there's no
like body issues or anything um I don't
know I I I need romance I guess a little
bit I
need
um you
know I guess romance maybe is a starting
point and when somebody says romance
that often means um and I'm I'm I
normally I would just sit here and make
you like not I would make you go through
the motions of here I want to be be
specific about the things I believe
would lead to
this erotic
attraction um and you've been through a
lot you've been through all the normal
things that people do when they Google
like hey what do I do
right but often those are tactics or
they are specifics or they are focused
on the ACT once the bedroom door closes
right and when somebody says romance
often what they mean is I need a
different
context I need my life to feel and look
different so that I can be erotic inside
this world that you and I are
co-creating okay does that sound right
or no it does sound right but I don't
know how to I don't know what to do with
that um do you know what I'm saying like
how do I other than
being honest with
him
T that's that's step one
um here's the hard place you find
yourself you're going to have to sit
down to a man that you love that you've
spent probably more time with him in
your life than you have without him is
that
fair yes and you're going to have to say
I haven't told you the truth for about
years okay and from that conversation
and it will be
devastating one because he's hurt you
for so long he didn't know he
was two the dishonesty this is going to
be a hard hard
path his world will be uneven he won't
be able to stand on the foundation that
he thought his life was and in a weird
way it'll be such a great
relief I've talked with couples before
that say things like I wish she would
just tell me she's cheating on me then I
wouldn't feel so
insane
we'd have to deal with the infidelity
and I'd have to get a new life and all
that but God at least I wouldn't be feel
like I'm crazy and
so but when you do this have this
conversation you're GNA have to be
specific about what has to happen in
this new marriage youall have to build
because you're not going backwards to
when y'all were dating you're going to
have to decide we're going to build
something totally new and that's where
you have to be specific in this new
marriage here's what romance feels and
looks like to
me you're on you're on time to
things you help pick up the
kids there's never dishes in the sink
after I cook dinner you've got to go get
a job you have to quit drinking after
you know you see what I'm
saying the
specifics and after 30 years he needs a
road map to your heart because he
thought he was there and he is
not okay that doesn't mean that this is
all going to fix your sexual dysfunction
it's going to give it a a
chance
right the last question I have for you
is this do you
want to feel sexual desire or do you
want to want to feel sexual desire
towards him and you get the difference
in that
question um not not entirely no I would
love to want to live in New York
City the energy the fun the constant
noise and in like the the like all of it
I'd love to want to do that it sounds
like it would be fun I don't my wife
would love to love my wife would love to
want to go to punk rock shows with
me they're too loud and I like MH
pitting even though I'm old and she
doesn't like that
right that's that's step one the other
side of it that's not step one but
that's one side I want to want to live
in New York but I don't like
it I like nature and I like trees and I
like the woods and I like a slower Pace
okay it's why I like Texas it's why I
like Tennessee it's why I like Kentucky
I like some of these slower places okay
on the other side
um if you want
to like I want to get in shape well cool
then i' there's a thousand plans out
there to go get in shape I'm going to
follow one of those plans and the shape
part will take will happen does that
make
sense yeah it does so which one do which
where do you find
yourself do you just want to want to be
romantically attracted to him this just
not going to happen or no I want to I'm
going to deal with this hard stuff and
then we're gonna go try to make that
happen no I want to okay all right that
at least tells me you'll have a chance
okay otherwise your honesty conversation
is totally
different
okay
okay and can I ask you one more question
before we go sure when you met with a
therapist they didn't tell you
this
um I
mean they didn't say you got to be
honest and tell the
truth I think they were playing off of
my reluctance maybe or just giving into
my reluctance to be honest maybe I I no
not in that not in that straightforward
manner no one said that to me
no I'm sorry man you got really bad bad
support and
care it's brutal
dude if I'm you here's how I would start
the conversation I would say we have to
have a hard conversation it's going to
take a few hours and it's going to be
tough for you to process and I haven't
cheated on you the marriage isn't over
so I didn't do any I didn't spend a
million dollar
like and also I want to be married to
you I want to love you the best I can
and I want to give you a road map to
love me and for 30 years I've withheld
that road map and I'm sorry and in fact
I'm still figuring out what it
is but there can be no intimacy there
can be no new marriage there can be no
relationship without me without me first
being honest with you so we're going to
start we're going to re repour the
foundation today and it's with honesty
and I'm going to go
first and then he may need silence he
may need a week he may need what who
knows what he'll need but I want you to
be gracious enough and give it to him
and he's going to come back with a bunch
of questions he's going to first think
what else have you lied about what else
this what be prepared for all that and
be prepared to say in this new marriage
I want to
build here's some things I'm going to
need
so that we can build an erotic ethos in
this home a home that pulses with
romance that pulses with desire that
starts with us building something
totally
new and for everybody listening for
God's sakes you have to tell the truth
in your marriage period even when it's
hard especially when it's
hard lying never solves a thing in a
marriage we'll be right back
I'm always on the lookout for
supplements food and top-of-the-line
products that enhance your immune system
improve emotional and mental health
vastly improve your digestion and I'm
always looking for ways I can improve my
sleep and Clarity of thought listen I'm
always trying different supplements
Foods powders and potions and recently
without the company knowing I purchased
some of their products with my own money
and I was blown away by the results I
reached out to them and I'm super
excited that organifi is partnering with
me on this podcast to change my life and
yours simply put organifi is Wellness
Made Easy organifi makes nutrition
delicious for everybody organifi makes
the cleanest products available on the
market and me and my kids personally
take multiple organifi products every
single day my life has changed for the
better from what I think are the best
tasting green powders on the market red
powders that I can mix with water for
caffeine-free energy that doesn't leave
me shaking like a salt shaker gold
powders to help me wind down in sleep
immunity protein magnesium and a special
kids line and more organifi takes all
the drama and guesswork out of nutrition
supplements immunity support and
cognitive enhancement and it puts it all
in one place for you and your entire
family you all know I like to experiment
and take lots of different supplements
but if I had to answer the question if I
only had one supplement I could take
what would it be I'd start with organifi
invest in your health in this new year
so you can show up for your spouse your
kids your work and your community we
need you go to organifi.com
backone or use promo code deloney at
checkout for a 20% discount for all the
Dr John delone show listeners that's
organifi.com
delone all right let's go out to the Ute
Salt Lake City Utah and talk to Chad
what up
Chad hello Dr deloney my question uh
today is how
how I may Empower my
[Applause]
wife well tell me some more Empower her
for
what well she's she's been diagnosed
with depression anxiety and ab add and
takes medication for all of those and
has done for quite some
time
and I I question her intention with it
she doesn't seen any conversation we've
had or even the the doctor that
prescribes the medication to her is
encourages her to go get help uh outside
of just taking the medication but she's
pretty reluctant to
seek uh
counseling and I question I'm
questioning if I'm doing a disservice
for her when I go to pick up her
medication and I'm not encouraging
her uh to go get more than just taking
medication kind of help H and I'm really
just looking for ways that I
can help her I I've doesn't seem to be a
whole lot out there yeah I don't that's
tough how long have you been married
Chad well been married for seven years
but we've been together for 10 hey I may
be crazy but I hear in your voice that
you are out of your mind in love with
her I am yeah and you're scared to death
am I crazy's AB no you're not I I
absolutely adore it she's beautiful it's
it's difficult to tell her that because
she's she's hesitant to hear it she's
like stop I don't you know I know she's
she struggles with body image as well
that kind of gets in the way of things
yeah and so so here's a let's just play
that one out right one of the challenges
with loving somebody let's P let's pull
these apart real fast somebody who
struggles with body image issues is
yeah we think that oh you just need to
hear that you're
beautiful right and actually that can
make the gap between us wider because
they're like oh you don't see it you're
crazy yeah or you're lying to me too
right or somebody who's struggling with
depression it's easier to be like oh
let's go do something fun look how
beautiful it is and that actually in a
weird perverse
way separates us even further right yeah
I know exactly what you're saying yeah I
hate that for you man cuz it sounds like
she married a guy who loves her like in
a wild way and has just been trying hard
and so dude on behalf of men everywhere
who love their wives and are just trying
to do the next best right thing I'm
grateful for you
man pretty awesome appreciate yourg man
thank you well
I this is one of those things that you
can't just go to your buddies and talk
about it and so you end up doing a lot
of this alone and I talk to millions of
men across the not Millions but
countless men across the country and
they're dealing with the same thing I'm
trying to love my wife behind closed
doors right and I to say complaining
about her is does no good either like
it's it's difficult to have
conversations with like guys I work with
because everybody wants to complain or
something and it's and I up to that
point I I I feel like I don't want to
contribute to that anymore and I just
Hey listen to this so one time um it was
20 years ago it was yeah it was probably
right at 20 years ago um he's become a
close friend of mine his name's Eric
Peters he's a musician and a painter
here in Nashville
and we were doing some things together
and um I was on stage one night and he
and I was making a joke about my wife
and my wife and I been barely
married and he's a Eric is a small guy
and I'm a big loudmouth idiot and he's a
smaller guy and kind of quiet and very
uh very Arty artistic he's amazing and
he just like casually said hey you know
what there's two kinds of husbands the
husbands that spend time making fun of
their wives and husbands that will never
say a negative thing and he said don't
be the first kind the world has enough
of them that's for weak men and I
remember thinking dude I'm GNA try my
best to not say anything negative about
my wife especially public ever now
that's not mean I don't talk to my
closest friends or a therapist or
something but anyway I applaud you
brother for not contributing to being
like yeah dude then my girl my don't be
that guy I'm proud of you dude that's
awesome okay let's walk through this so
the word empowerment simply means I want
to give her what she needs oh go ahead
go ahead go ahead I got that I I often
listen listen to books that you
recommend to your callers and one of
those books was by Terrence real I don't
want to talk about yeah that's where I
got this idea about um empowering my
wife because he said that's one of the
things he does when he recognizes like a
depressed husband he'll he'll
immediately like empower the wife and I
was like that just was like oh my gosh I
need to focus on that beautiful did you
like the book I did yeah that's awesome
man all right so what like let's just
Define it empowering simply means I'm
going to give her what she needs to be
successful okay I like it so often we
think especially men here's what you
need to be successful a hammer or a
wrench because those are the only two
tools we have in our toolkit all right
so I'm going to give you a couple of
different toolkits Fair yep okay um
toolkit number one gosh dude and by the
way every man listening to this is don't
let your eyes roll through the back of
your head I just want you to ask
yourself is what you're doing working
and most men will go all right not
really so I'm going to give you a
different set of tools and you're GNA be
like oh dude you simp you whatever
whatever I'm telling you one works and
one doesn't okay here we go the first
one is no telling her she needs to fill
in the blank you need to go to
counseling you need do this I'm not
getting your meds until you that's a
failed track okay you will you will join
the ranks of a million people in her
life perceptively her perception that a
million people don't get her don't
understand her are coming after her okay
yeah so your strange challenge is how do
I remain on her team while at the same
time Empower her and not enable her
right oh yeah that's where I'm that's
where I'm I I I'm really good at
enabling her I know exactly what you
mean by that okay so here's what we're
going to
do number one we're going to sit down
and you're going to say I want to be the
best husband I can
be it would really help me if you dot
dot dot here's what I want you to give
her two or three very small tasks can
you help set up the coffee in the
morning would you be willing to do a
budget with me on Sunday nights and talk
about our calendar coming up this week
for
me and what your doing is and this
sounds manipulative it's not it's
empowering her you're giving her a
couple of small tiny tasks so she can
get a couple of small wins relationally
and operationally she can see the coffee
being made she can see you smile after
you all do a quick budget meeting or a
quick calendar meeting on Sunday night
an invitation to get involved in small
things giving her a chance to win and
then letting her see it all over
you like three days into her making the
coffee in the morning you going hey I
just need to
stop I need you to hear me say every
single part of my morning and my day is
better because
you have stepped into this gap for me
thank you and she'll be like oh my gosh
it's like two seconds and you'll be like
I know and it makes such a difference
for me thank you okay beautiful right um
and so what we're looking for is a is a
series of little wins okay and you can
pick whatever that looks like I like
that okay number
two ask her hey it's year seven of us
being
married this is when husbands realize
they need to get better at what they do
would you be willing to go to counseling
with me because I want to be better at
husbanding and it has nothing to do with
her other than she's going to be able to
contribute to help help
you I've tried that but it was it it I
don't think the context was right at the
time but now it might be better to try
if you say hey I don't I don't know how
to be married to you our marriage is
falling apart you're going through this
I we need to go to counseling that's
gonna be tough yeah but hey would you
love me enough to come help me
out see how that it's subtle but you end
up in the same place you both end up on
a
couch y okay a third one is
structure can you create a 30 minute
meeting on Sunday evenings just say I'll
make dinner on Sunday nights moving
forward into this new year but would you
just do a quick R so we can talk through
the
week I find myself spinning out and I
get stressy and I don't want to bring
stressy home so if we can just run
through the calendar any dinners we have
this week any workouts we need to go do
whatever um would you do that with
me but what's going to happen after
month one and month two and month three
and month four of course you're going to
miss a couple of times but what you're
going to slowly build over time is this
relational
safety through an activity most people
think relational safety comes from just
talking a
lot it truly comes from accomplishing a
thing together something as small as a
calendar uh a discussion
okay that's that's great I like I really
like that minute just simple meeting
starting out once a week and build on
that but the and and let it know let her
know this is for you not for
her okay okay can you help
me because she loves you and she's
struggling and when we go ahead this is
difficult for me to ask for
help i' it is really tough I I
I the whole enabling thing I try to take
on so much and but you see you hear me
say this on my show all the time and uh
Terry real talks about too there's a
dance that happens and the dance becomes
somebody struggling with ADHD and
depression and anxiety this they feel
like their body and their feelings are
bigger than their
abilities and then they marry somebody
who hates asking for help and solves all
of their problems all the time Y and so
the ability to stand up on your own two
feet never happens because I don't ever
have to and the person who is trying to
uh achieve love solve for Love by fixing
stuff never grasps it it feels like a
ghost every time you take and get the
car oil changed or you do it yourself or
you fix the drywall patch or whatever
that you earn some money you're
expecting this now she'll fill in the
blank and it does
doesn't
right right so what we're doing is we're
flipping the whole thing on its
head and by the way I'm telling you this
is all for her this will help you
too yeah okay see that now there's a
couple of very nerdy things that I want
you to try also that are super kind of
woo woo but I want to give it a shot
okay that's no woooo is fine yeah let's
hear it I want you to try four times a
day right when you wake up right before
you leave right when you get home from
work like walk in the door she walks in
the door from work then right before
yall go to sleep I want you to try SOS
skin on skin contact does not have to be
sexual you don't take your shirts off or
anything you can but you hold hands
under the covers you can just touch
feet okay you can hug and when you hug
you can put your hand on the back of her
neck underneath her hair and she can do
the same thing to
you okay skin on skin contact four times
a day for about 10 15 30 seconds if you
want to get
weird okay and one of those times
probably right when you get get home
from work or right before you go to bed
I want you to say hey I read this
obnoxious thing that supposedly can help
my heart
rate and but I want you to uh make eye
contact with me uncomfortably and weird
for about 15 seconds would you do
that okay now there is some this is this
is me going out on a limb here okay this
is me taking one set of Science and
another set of Science and cobbling
together and I don't have I haven't read
this study okay so I'm I'm hoping that a
plus b will equal C here it might not
but I think it will okay okay 15 seconds
here's what here's why there's some
significant research that
says um eye contact for somebody who
struggles with social anxiety with
anxiety disorders of some of some sorts
it actually heightens their arousal
makes things worse
okay and makes things worse yes but but
hang on we also know that the research
on anxiety suggests you have to go
through it to give your body
peace and so when you avoid something
your body actually it reinforces the
anxiety so most of the time you hear the
studies it says x s anxiety disorder
plus eye contact equals a heightening of
the anxiety so that it's natural to go
well dude let's just avoid eye contact
but actually what that does is it makes
the anxiety
stronger okay so here's what I want to
do I want her to begin to feel and
experience you as
safe okay okay she probably does that
intellectually she knows you'll fight
for her she knows you can fix stuff
right yes I want her to feel that in her
nervous system okay I want her to feel
that too yes okay so let's get
weird okay and anybody listening to this
I think there's a benefit to this but I
want yall to make I contact in a weird
way and you'll laugh at first and she'll
want to look away and every time one of
y'all looks away um I want you to start
the 15 seconds over
again but here's what I want her to see
I want your eye crinkles to come out and
I want your eyes to soften when you're
looking in her eyes that's it and when
it's over be like that's it 15 seconds
we're done high five yeah high five
whatever I want this to become a
practice on a daily basis and say Hey I
want to do a 30-day challenge that I
heard about on some internet
show
okay okay after about a week of her
helping you with coffee um filling your
gas up fill in your carp with gas
whatever little small tasks you ask hey
can you support me
here I want you to write her a letter
and put on her
pillow and let her know that this week's
been one of the greatest weeks of your
life she can dismiss things that you say
people with depression and especially uh
ADHD can dismiss it anxiety can dismiss
the words or they can hear them
differently than you speak them but when
we write things down they go back and
they go back and they go back and they
go
back okay or if maybe if you want to get
super gangster if she' actually do this
she might not if yall have a journal
that you put on each other's pillow at
night I'll write in it tonight I'll put
on her journal she can read it and
respond to it and then I'll go back to
mine okay
okay I've been meaning to write a letter
I've been do to do that that's awesome
and maybe you take it out and if for for
the start of the new
year
um you read it to her and then you give
it to
her okay I like that now I want everyone
listening and you two to hear none of
this was about talking to her about her
depression anxiety or
ADHD it's not okay it's about giving her
body a space
and a person to
go and in a weird way you are going to
begin to grow too because you already do
the stuff right you exercise you're you
can yeah snap into a slim gym you do all
that stuff all that good stuff what I
want to do is connect with
her exactly yes and from that connection
only then can there be a conversation
about
um I'm going to go pick up your meds
um or when she's decides I'll go talk to
a counselor for you so you can become a
better husband fine I love you that
much yeah that maybe she extracts some
benefit from
it very nice he's giving me quite a few
things here to really think about and
contemplate and put into action cool and
by the way it sounds weird to talk to
for you to picture your wife and to ask
to think how am I going to help her by
asking her
to help me with a
thing yeah it's it is it's it's it's
it's it's sensitive and it's there's
some fear in me I'm not going to lie I
have to admit it's scary to have
difficult conversations like that there
and I know I'm not the best at it yet I
don't I'm work I I'm reading a lot and
sometimes reading a lot of books I like
I've read all of your books I read about
five years in the
work making myself better included and
it can get overwhelming sometimes all
the information you get right and and
I'm going to tell you quit reading
you've already read my two books
right uh yeah okay quit reading I just
want to make sure you bought my books
before I told you that I'm just playing
but listen yeah U let's stop reading for
a while let's start doing let's start
doing yeah that's that's the part
sometimes that's where it gets
overwhelming you're like okay now I need
to start practicing these a lot of these
things I'm learning about and it's like
okay well I don't really know how where
do you start and it makes me you're
overwhelmed and you don't even know
where to begin and so dude you just said
it
perfect if I could get every husband in
the United States to say what you just
said I think our culture would change
overnight and that is
honey I'm not very good at
this but I'm GNA start trying something
new I'm still going to protect us I'm
still going to provide for us I'm still
going to take care of us I'm still going
to co-parent I'm going to do all those
things
and yeah I feel that
okay
and I want I want to practice I want to
learn how to connect with
you and she's gonna go what we do
connect we do oh God it's about sex no
no no no no no this is about me learning
how to listen and me learning how to
like practice new things I read all
these great books I want to start
practicing it could you help me within
the following ways a week meeting would
you be will to do that for
me there's three things in the morning
before I go to work that are just I I
just always find myself struggling with
it it would change my life if you would
help me with
these and by the way if she doesn't
that's fine it may not be time for her
yet she may still be struggling or she
gets three days and the fourth day
there's no coffee in there you can make
it I yeah don't take it personally
yeah it's little wins little wins I like
that little wins cool
cool all right hang on the line I'm
going to send you both of the questions
for humans for couples here's what these
are going to give you guys
a just a quiet path in the woods for new
conversations what we're doing here is
we're building intimacy we are healing
nervous
systems and if once a week at your uh
calendar meeting if youall just have a a
quick hey um let's let's do three
questions or let's go for a drive let's
go out for to eat eat um somewhere cheap
and we're going to do some qu whatever
it looks like now me and my wife started
driving um we've gotten several
questions since now we when we drive we
just do it I just like it I learn new
things about my wife the person I've
been with for a quarter Century all the
time and vice versa and um dude I'm so
proud of you it's an honor to get to get
to talk to you and get to know you if um
you'll try some of these things I'd love
to hear how it goes okay I'd love to
hear how it goes and please make sure
your wife continues with her medical
care
and continues to work with a medical
provider who's encouraging her to go to
counseling the evidence is abundantly
clear that medication plus therapy is
the gold standard so we got to get her
in there some point but we're going to
do it a different way not by pointing
fingers but by opening our chests up a
little bit opening up our souls and
saying um I don't know how to do this
but uh let's try connecting proud of you
brother I'm glad to know you're in the
community with me we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's delone last year I came to
an inflection point I was exercising
regularly I was disciplined in my diet I
was getting regular blood work done and
I was working hard on my marriage I was
doing all the right things but I had not
dealt with old traumas and old stories
that were negatively impacting my
marriage my relationship with my kids my
work and me I'm the expert I teach
others what to do but I was slowly piece
by piece falling apart so I swallowed my
pride and with the encouragement of my
family and friends I reached out to a
therapist and started seeking true deep
healing a year later I'm a radically
different man all for the better and I
know finding a therapist in your local
community can be almost impossible or if
you do find one it's so expensive you
can't afford to go even if you wanted to
and that's why I love the work better
help is doing in the world better help
is online therapy with real licensed
therapists who are a available on your
schedule when you contact better help
you will fill out a short questionnaire
and they will match you with the
licensed therapist plus you can switch
therapist at any time for no extra
charge you've been working so so hard
and now it's time to get to the root of
your pain for permanent extraordinary
life change visit betterhelp.com dealone
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com
delone all right we're back let's go out
to Cincinnati and talk to Jennifer
what's up
Jennifer oh hi hi there Dr John what's
up so my question is this hold on that
was that was a big
sigh tell me it's the holiday season and
you're about to ask a really complex
question without saying
anything all right let's do
it okay how do I approach the presence
of my uncle at family gathering
ings there's a long history in our
family around my uncle um 20 years ago
my little brother who was about 10 at
the time reported that my uncle had
masturbated in front of him on a camping
trip my uncle told him not to tell uh
police got involved but my brother
turned out to be an unreliable witness
and so the case didn't really go
anywhere U my cousin my uncle's son has
confronted his father and alleged that
he was molested by his father um but so
he's current no contact with his dad my
uncle um my uncle denies all these
allegations seems very sad at you know
the loss of all the connection but my
dad is his older
brother still there yeah I'm here he's
still there okay I got his text my dad
is very loyal to his younger brother um
invites him to our family gatherings now
when he's got no
plans um so I I feel so much tension
about this I mean there's no legal
convictions and he's this human sitting
across from me at the table at
Gatherings and my cousin feels betrayed
um that his father is still welcomed at
Gatherings despite way he went through
and my younger brother um not to mention
him he still acts like nothing even
happened um should I like protest that
he's invited to these things should I
not hug him when he walks in the door am
I complicit in this by not saying
anything like how do I how do I approach
this what's my posture towards him in
this yeah what a mess
um when I I think I missed something
your brother said he just acts like
nothing happened or your uncle acts like
nothing nothing happen they both do
everyone does oh okay um well I think
there's a clear reason why people act
like that because your brother did
something scary and terrifying and told
the truth and nothing happened except in
a way he got in trouble right when
you're 10 and you have to go meet with
cops and you have to do all these things
and they ultimately say you're not
reliable
uhhuh um you get a message loud and
clear shut your mouth nobody cares what
you have to say yeah followed up by
somebody else his age reports
something again nothing
happens right right so everybody has a
very clear message that um uh nothing
happened right except I am from the old
school where there's smoke there's fire
and if two young boys that have a lot to
lose
both Point their fingers in a very
similar way to
somebody
um it's very rare like the movies where
two pathologic a cousin and a brother
get together and like hey let's take
down like that just doesn't h i mean
anyway I'm I'm of the old
school that where there's smoke there's
fire do you have kids yeah no okay so
this is this is is l oh you're the fun
an okay so this is largely about
you yeah have you asked your cousin and
your brother their feelings their
thoughts their ideas on all of
this uh I know my cousin's thoughts and
feelings about it so you're your cousin
just doesn't won't
come right he doesn't have any
interaction with his dad and he thinks
everyone is a huge hypocrite who acts
like everything's fine and now he
doesn't come to things because his dad
is that things right and his kids don't
come you know
sure if I'd been molested by somebody
I'm not going to let my kids be around
them right right um so yeah let's let's
play this back let's say your uncle
really did do these things a there's
more boys out there who are now men that
this happened
to
and think how his son
feels to have the courage to come out
and say the hardest thing you could ever
say against against your a person
against your
dad and he lost his family over it not
the other way
around it's pretty terrible yeah I mean
wow and let's just conf I mean you
you've mentioned some pretty important
things about Humanity of course your
uncle's sad of course he is he lost
everything but him being sad isn't why
I'm going
to
um in any way compromise my values still
can do what I think is right so let me
ask you you this I can't give you this
answer what do you think is
right I mean I'm inclined to believe the
children who said that an
adult violated them violated their
innocence um I struggle with I didn't
invite him to my gathering my parents
invited him to theirs so sometimes our
parents do things that uh um you've
heard me say this a million times
behavior is a
language yes and so if you invite them
then you're telling me you don't want me
to come that's great happy holidays okay
I do think that's a conversation to have
with your dad it's a grown-up
conversation that would be highly
uncomfortable for you but you're an
adult you can do it say Hey Dad I've
reached a point where I can't be in his
presence
anymore okay and so if you choose to
invite him he's your brother I get it
there's no legal findings I know but
I've talked to our our I've talked to
your
son and you're choosing your brother
over your son you're allowed to do that
but I'm gonna spend holidays with him
and um this other man's
son and by the way I would be stunned
stunned if your dad didn't have an
inkling one way or the
other he acts like he's pretty
confident um that his son just made up a
huge lie about his
brother
yeah in law enforcement so he swears up
and down he knows to tell when people
arey of course they do you should you
should read the data on that and I'm
know not any better than anybody else
nope but they're infinitely more
confident than they are way more
confident that's right that's
right I'm sorry it's a
mess it's not fun
yeah
um I'll tell you what I would do I'll
tell you what I would
do if um I have little brother he's not
little he's a grown man but I have a
little brother and if he came forward
and said this about one of my
uncles when he was 10 this this thing
happened and then I had another cousin
come out and say this thing about his
dad
M that would be enough for me that I
would choose to be with my little
brother okay that's just me that's not a
right or wrong it's not up or down yes
people make up things I've been a part
of those investigations too I know that
yes they do and it's not very
common and not from multiple sources and
not when people have get investigated
yeah people don't get investigated times
over different years for the same thing
and still be
innocent uh I mean maybe but it's just
it's a that's why he's not in jail cuz
maybe right yeah
um what does your gut tell
you my gut tells me that my that the
kids told the truth okay follow your
gut
and Jennifer I know what that means that
means hell I
know yeah and I'm I don't like to make
trouble I know Trouble made
you and if your uncle actually did these
things um he's the one who chose to burn
down your family tree not you you're
trying to replant it in fertile
soil yes fertile soil
yes okay
all right and this is all
different because there's a potential
child molester in the mix there is all
different because there's no repentance
there was no I screwed up there's no
redemp I mean there's nothing to be
redeemed here it's it's it's a adults
versus multiple kids and the adult
one now maybe when you meet with your
dad your dad could say hey I'm going to
show you some evidence that you didn't
know existed when you were young
younger um those boys got together and
made this whole thing up
check everybody
okay yeah no the dog sees the mailman
okay cool um so may maybe that's the
case I I'm think there's a
0.00000000 1% chance that's that's the
case sounds more
like um your dad doesn't want to believe
this and can't believe this about his
brother and so he chose his brother over
his son and thought ah he's just a kid
he'll get over it by the way parents if
your kids come to you with this sort of
hey this happen to me when it comes to
sexual abuse always default to believing
your children first
always
always that sounds really not like them
always start with I believe
you always Jennifer I'm sorry sry not by
your hand but in your lap this mess came
upon you
and conversations I would start my
little
brother and maybe you have to start and
say I'm sorry I believed you but I've
just kept showing up cuz I don't like to
make trouble and Jennifer got a pair of
boxing gloves for Christmas and so I'm
going to make some trouble by the way
everybody listening to this this call is
coming before the holidays and I'm
imagining Jennifer's entering into the
holiday season and you'll be hearing
this after some of these hard
conversations so Jennifer feel free to
call us back and let us know how those
conversations
went we'll be right back hey what's up
delone here listen you and me and
everybody else on the planet has felt
anxious or burned out or chronically
stressed at some point in my new book
building a non-anxious life you'll learn
the six daily choices that you can make
to get rid of your anxious feelings and
be able to better respond to whatever
life life throws at you so you can build
a more peaceful nonanxious life get your
copy today at John
del. all right we are back in an honor
of
Jenna the song of the days from the
great Taylor Swift oh Teddy swims shoot
I saw TS and I just thought it was
Taylor Swift learn to read I know looked
on Phonics and not work for me yeah cuz
trust me if I'm sitting here we're not
picking a Taylor I was gonna say I was
surprised Kelly turned her into a Swifty
apparently no Teddy swims phenomenal
Teddy swims song's called some things
I'll never know walking down the street
last night watching strangers Pass Me By
where do all our shadows go I guess some
things I'll never know I can fool my
senses for a little while but some
things are too hard to reconcile I guess
some things I'll never know like how
many tattoos does Kelly really have lots
and lots oh she's not telling the truth
hey stay at school don't do drugs happy
New Year
bye